right but though
the more problems the more money the
worse the problem the more money you
make
right yeah absolutely what do you say
what do you say to somebody
who is like small time wants to get in
the real estate game right now maybe
they have enough
they have enough credit and and capital
to maybe get a down payment on like this
one single family home
right and they want to get started in
all this what do they do
so basically you know i i you know i
hear a lot of like um
credit has more value than money and
blah blah blah i mean that's true to a
certain extent but in reality it doesn't
because once again if you're not going
to dwell 51 percent of the of your asset
that you're going to purchase
the bank is going to have a difficult
time selling you the asset or excuse me
wait explain that again if you're not
going to do what
so basically banks lend money to people
who are going to live
in the asset if it's commercial property
you're going to use at least 51
okay so that's you know with limited
down payment three percent
five ten like an fha loan yeah fha
conventional with small down payments
but what i would tell anybody that just
that type of person
look just try to find an area do the
comparables
you know i mean look at sales try to
find something
that is not that big that you can add
square footage later on because it's
cheaper to add square footage than to
buy a big house
because let me give an example let's say
you buy a two-bedroom one-bedroom
bedroom one bath house a thousand square
feet
in an area that's bringing 350 a foot
right okay
and you buy the house you could always
build an
addition for a hundred dollars 120 a
foot
right so now you tripled doubled to
tripled your money
on the added square footage you're doing
so then you could resell that house and
make more money
or you could uh get a second the line of
credit heloc
or that you know then you could use that
money to go make money
so there's very that's what i would do
if i had limited capital
yeah i would try to get a house that's
very small in a good neighborhood
okay then what i would do is i'd get a
gc to get plans
to build uh square footage added square
footage then build the added square
footage
now my house is worth more money and i'd
immediately sell it i wouldn't get it
i wouldn't get a heloc anything i would
take the money then i'd stay in the same
neighborhood by renting a house
take the money and go buying some
jalopies in worse neighborhoods and just
keep re-flipping them
so you would keep doing that same thing
just adding buying them buying
decent houses and or decent or bad
houses in good neighborhoods adding
square footage
i've done that many times you know what
i heard i was just watching this video
this dude bought a [ __ ]
uh like a mansion in california and he
said what the realtors are doing now
in california like specifically beverly
beverly hills area
is they're building these [ __ ] like
pool cabanas
out of block and they're counting them
and they're literally counting them as
square footage
like so even if it's like a couple
hundred square feet like like a pool
house out back
yeah well think about it if you have a
uh if you have a carport that's 250
square feet
yeah and it costs you 30 000 to
encapsulate that with heated
square footage and it's 250 square feet
and it goes for
300 a foot that 25 turned into 75.
so your cash on cash investment tripled
right but can you just do it yourself do
you have to [ __ ] go get out and get
permits and do all that
well you have to have everything
permitted otherwise it's not going to be
on the tax record
okay and then when you go to sell it you
don't want any problems see like taking
shortcuts is the worst thing you can do
really
of course anytime you try to do
something that's not 100 legit you're
going to get busted
and then that's just going to cost you
time energy and money do it right the
first time and you'll never look back
never screw anybody over you never have
to sleep bad you never have to look over
your back
always have to be a man of your word
because in reality what else do you
really have
yeah you know what i'm saying because
business is a way of life
you know a lot of people talk to me
brian how do i get in this part i said
look to be honest with you
real estate is not a job it's not a
profession
it's basically a lifestyle yeah you
constantly have to be thinking when i go
on vacation i try to buy places where i
go
oh maybe i could buy this here airbnb or
something yeah
you know you always constantly have to
be on a mental grind
can you walk me through one of these
deals that you're talking about these
new construction deals like what what do
you look for like obviously you buy it
starts with buying land and
you've got to yeah so
yeah murder your thirst got it all right
so
you look at the area and you see what
the new houses are bringing
so let's say we're building at 110 a
foot
due to the fact that the wood has gone
up and the trusses are hard to find so
whatever
so if you're selling at 110 a foot
and you build a 2 500 square foot house
right so so
the cost to build a new house is about
110 a foot right plus your impact fees
the price of the dirt right so you got
to work backwards so let's say that
let's just use round numbers again
let's say the house is selling for 300 a
foot okay and you build 2 000 square
feet
okay so you already know your retail
number six hundred thousand dollars
so you're probably going to have to back
out about eight percent
because you got to pay when you sell it
real estate commissions and closing
costs
got it all right so you're gonna net 92
of your sale price okay okay so let's
say 92
of 600 let me see it's 540 plus that's
like 550 to 2
000. so you're gonna net 550 on that
sale right
and if it's 2 000 square feet and it
costs you two and a quarter to build it
so now you got 325 in between profit and
dirt
and all fees okay so if you could buy
that dirt for 150
000 at the end of the day you're gonna
make about 150
000 on that deal and but that's
including if you're paying cash for
everything
you're not using anybody else's money no
no no financing or anything right no
financing
wow but that's a lot of i think that
takes a long time though that's like a
long time
now you're looking at about six months
but remember if you got six months to
build a house probably like three to
four months but let's say you got
20 or 30 of those going at one shot holy
[ __ ] well every week you're cashing a
check
and then you buy dirt like we make money
by buying large parcels of dirt
and knowing the future land use and
doing a pd which is a planned
development and bill getting the plans
ready
so we take that and we sell it to the
builders
so like i have a property i bought for
250 000
and it's costing me like 50 000 to get
it to where it needs to be pete planned
development
for 60 units so i'm going to be in that
property for like 300 000 and i'm gonna
list it for 1.8 million
so once i sell it let's say i take one
five after fees
i net one three i'll make a million
dollars on that asset with 300 000
out of pocket because i happen to get
the dirt cheap enough
and i know the zoning and i know what i
can do with it so
obviously knowledge is always supreme so
you have to know what you're doing
before you do it and when you're selling
that piece of property you're selling
the dirt
and you're selling there's already
permits in place to build
there's selling what it's going to be
and you're going to sell that to a guy
who does build and
sells because he's going to take a 1031
exchange which is basically
he's going to use the proceeds from his
last sale to do the same thing over and
over again
this way he doesn't have to pay the
government high taxes
so basically they're they're buying a
piece of property turnkey ready to be
built on you have the permits you got
the plans you got the builder
everything and because a lot of builders
they don't really have much money and
they use the bank's money so the time
once going back to
our original statement time is very
precious
so they're using our asset that we
purchased develop it for them to get
ready
so that's how we make a large
substantial hit
okay wow so do you do any uh 1031
exchanges nah not really because i move
pretty fast and i don't mind paying the
government
because it's easier for me and it's just
less headaches
yeah it's a lot it's a lot of stress to
chase that window
and i'm i'm the kind of guy that i just
i just like a simple life
you know i you know sometimes i go crazy
do me but i just like to have fun